Speaker 1: I want to follow up a little bit
about the accused criminals who participated in
rioting, destruction of property, sometimes
violence against individuals. On January six,
2021, colloquially known as the Trump
riots, you know, the rioters were
overwhelmingly from a political movement
that claims to be about the rule of law
and following the rules and doing what the
law prescribes. And yet they broke the law.
They broke the law by trespassing. They
broke the law with vandalism and entering
the Capitol building. They broke the law, in
some cases by attacking police officers. They
broke the law, in some cases by stealing things
from the Capitol. Some of them also destroyed
the property of media outlets outside the Capitol.
They broke the law and many different ways. But
once you are accused of breaking the law, they
believe in due process. And of course, due process
includes both sides of it. It includes due process
by those prosecuting you and law enforcement. But
it also includes facing the charges against you
and fighting them as you are able to do and given
a right to do with appropriate counsel through
the judicial system. But they're not all doing
that either. After allegedly breaking the law on
January six, at least one individual has fled the
country and is now desperately asking Belarus an
authoritarian state at this point in its own right
for asylum to recover in order to avoid facing
charges here in the United States. This is
an extraordinary story. A guy named Evan
Newman from California has started to plead
with Belarus on bail Russian state TV to let him
avoid justice here in the United States. This is
wild, and we're going to look at a video of this.
Evan Newman is wanted in the U.S. on six criminal
charges related to the attempted insurrection on
January six, including two felonies for assaulting
an officer. Now remember the right claims to
be about support the police law and order due
process. So Guy is accused of assaulting
officers. The right should be saying, Oh,
this guy's got to be held accountable. This guy
is now trying to avoid even facing justice. Wait,
that's not law and order. He was featured in The
Bell, a Russian state TV special Goodbye America.
He recounted a treacherous, treacherous journey
through forested borderlands that landed him in
Minsk and expressed his unwillingness to face
justice in the U.S.. Newman says he's seeking
political asylum in Belarus because the U.S.,
in his opinion, is no longer a country of law
and order. Think about that. Think about that for
a second. They say they are about law and order.
They then break the law and say, I'm going to flee
justice because my prosecution is no longer law
and order. What? This is another example of these
are our principles, and they are so important
until they're no longer convenient for
us. Check out this video This video is
from, I believe, i24 news and this special where
Evan Newman is pleading for asylum in Belarus to
avoid justice. It's obviously not in English,
so this is sort of like dubbed. It'll give you
a sense of what's going on. Let's take a look
Speaker 2: for America's critics. The Jan. six
riot at the US Capitol was already a propaganda.
Casting the nation as chaotic and violent.
But the bizarre appearance of Eva Newman,
an accused Capitol rioter from California
seeking asylum in Belarus, right one of the
world's most authoritarian dictatorships,
was more than the regime here could have hoped
for. Speed friendly media protests against 23,
though I see. Goodbye, America.
It's much easier for him to suggest
this is they're heavily promoted.
New special dubbed Goodbye America
on Bella Russian state TV. I thought I was all,
Speaker 1: by the way. I also it's also funny how
these very same law and order people who broke
the law allegedly and then are fleeing justice.
They also claim to be all about America, except
they seem to not understand their role in
furthering anti-American propaganda by showing
up in Belarus and demanding asylum to avoid
actually facing justice in the United States.
Speaker 2: The US is now settling scores,
the anchor says, with opponents of the US
regime fleeing right and even had to flee the
country or face prison and torture, simply taking
part in protests. She falsely claimed to then show
Newman himself being interviewed about how he got
here, apparently by crossing the border illegally
through snake infested swamps. By the way,
Speaker 1: they also say you got to come
in legally, but he has abandoned that
principle and crossed into Belarus illegally,
but says it's justified because the law and
order charges against him, he feels, are bogus.
Speaker 2: And, of course, why he came. He speaks
English, but he's voiced over in Russian, so it's
hard to hear his actual words. They released
a picture of my year for the before landing.
He says his photo was put on an FBI wanted
list. That's true. But his next claim isn't
what happened to other people there. What do
you think they do with people like me? He asked,
and kept in solitary confinement for eight months
at a time, and beaten torture is a common thing,
he explains to the Belarussian reporter. Torture
is, of course, illegal in the United States. What
is true is that Newman faces multiple criminal
charges in the US for his alleged role in the
Jan. six insurrection. Prosecutors say he taunted
and screamed at police before donning a gas mask
and threatening officers, according to
court papers. Police body camera footage
showed Newman pushing a metal barricade into a
police line before punching two officers with
his fist. I didn't decide to get any additional
support. He doesn't even deny he's taking part
and we were invited to come in, but we were
Speaker 1: there because, right? It's just
absolutely disgusting. So listen. Another one
of these examples, every principle is abandoned.
Immigration must be legal. Goes illegally to
Belarus. Law and order must be followed. Commits
alleged crimes, which are on video on Jan. six.
We must face justice and due process, and all
of this different stuff flees as a fugitive to a
different country. All of these principles mean
nothing to them. They mean nothing when the rubber
hits the road. And this is just another example